TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, and
welcome to episode
seven of Game On!
I am Todd Kerpelman.
I am your host and a Developer
Advocate on
the Play Games Team.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
Wolff Dobson.
I'm the Developer Programs
Engineer on
the Play Games Team.
And we're here to talk to you
about the latest in the Play
Game services API.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're here to
talk about management tools.
And we're going to end with
a special surprise.
And I don't want to give too
much way, but it's a graph.
So I guess I kind
of gave it away.
All right.
Let's move on to News
and Updates.
We don't really have any.
Not a whole lot happened.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's
going great.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
been relatively--
WOLFF DOBSON: Keep playing
those games.
TODD KERPELMAN: Keep
playing games.
And I guess no news
is good news.
So we'll move on to This Week's
Topic, which are the
management APIs.
These are a set of APIs we've
had available for a while, but
I'm not sure people have taken
advantage of them to the
extent that they should have.
And so Wolff has come to the
rescue on behalf of all you
developers.
And he's made life
easier for you.
So we're going to have
him talk about it.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
So the admin tools--
here's this link to the
docs if you want to
check them out yourself.
Basically, they are a bunch of
REST calls that allow you to
do certain management tasks,
like reset achievements, hide
players on high score lists,
un-unlock achievements--
that sort of thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Reset
your score--
WOLFF DOBSON: You've got it.
TODD KERPELMAN: --while
youre in testing.
WOLFF DOBSON: And I bet when I
say that, you're thinking, I
don't want to make all these
REST calls myself.
I wish somebody had actually
written that for me.
And the answer is
somebody has.
And that person is me.
So let's take a look.
So here's the first
of three tools.
This is the Play Games
Score-o-matic.
And what this allows you
to do is set and
reset leaderboard scores.
So this is the leaderboard from
Firewall Defense, Bruno's
excellent game.
And I can get the scores
that I've submitted.
Now, I haven't submitted any
scores, so let's make myself
score a whole bunch of scores.
I'm going to score
10,000 points.
And it says, great.
Your score is submitted.
And then if I call to
get my scores, I've
scored 10,000 points.
And I'm first in my social
group of two.
TODD KERPELMAN: How come you're
listed three times there?
WOLFF DOBSON: That's for
all-time high score, weekly
high score, and daily
high score.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And I can reset
all the scores with one click
of a button.
I'm reset--
boink.
And when I get my scores again,
I've disappeared.
TODD KERPELMAN: Ah.
So this would be very
useful if, say,
we're testing our game.
Our scoreboard is full of
testers that have either found
bugs to get ridiculously
high scores, and
we're like, oh man.
We've got to clear this
out before we launch.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Or you have a system that does
something special when you get
daily high scores or something
like that.
You want to be able to set
that off again and again.
So this is a way for
you to reset that.
You can only reset
your high score.
You can't reset everybody's
high score.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
That's probably important
to know.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
Next up is the Reset-o-matic.
The Reset-o-matic is the
same thing, except for
achievements.
So here, we have a list of
achievements in Firewall Defense.
I'm going to take this
cadet thing, and I'm
going to unlock it.
Da-ding--
achievement unlocked.
And when I refresh this--
phoomph--
you can see it is
now unlocked.
Hooray.
I could also, if it were an
incremental achievement,
increment it.
And I can also just say,
nah, I didn't win
that on second thought.
And when I refresh,
it is now still
revealed rather than unlocked.
TODD KERPELMAN: Revealed
here meaning that--
I always find our achievement
states confusing.
Revealed means that you know
the achievement is, but you
haven't earned it yet--
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: --as
opposed to hidden.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or unlocked, which
means you've actually--
achievement unlocked.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
And so this is incredibly
useful if, again, we're
testing achievements before
our game goes out.
And we want to practice earning
an achievement, we
want to test that over
and over again.
You don't have to create
500 test accounts.
We just--
WOLFF DOBSON: No, you wouldn't
want to do that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah-- reset
this achievement.
WOLFF DOBSON: You'd be sad.
OK.
So then lastly, we have
the Hide-o-matic.
And the Hide-o-matic is the one
that you're really going
to use, possibly, from week
to week when you're
developing your game.
So this is the main high score
list for Firewall Defense.
And you might look through here,
and you say, well, all
these guys got their scores
legitimately.
But when I say I look through
here, I see Bruno.
And Bruno is a developer
of the game.
It's clear he didn't score those
6,000 points by himself.
TODD KERPELMAN: No way.
WOLFF DOBSON: So I'm going
to go here, and I'm
going to say, be gone.
I'm going to hide you forever.
And so this player's
now hidden.
And if I refresh the high
scores and I page to the
second page, you can
see there's no
Bruno there any longer.
That's totally cool.
And if I decide to have mercy on
Bruno and bring him back, I
can click Unhide and
he's unhidden.
It'll take 12 hours for
Bruno to reappear.
It's a low priority job, so it's
going to come back when
it's going to come back.
TODD KERPELMAN: Now, when you
hide this player, are they
hidden from all leaderboards,
or just this particularly
leaderboard?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, they are
hidden from all leaderboards.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
Well, those are the
management tools.
These are all open source.
You can get them yourself
from GitHub
from our regular samples.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I guess it's
probably worth noticing,
compared to most of our sample
apps that are like, hey,
here's a sample that you can see
how it works, but then you
need to go and make your own
game and copy and paste bits
here and there from our samples,
this is really
intended for people to
essentially use as an entire
application.
You download this thing.
They run it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: And in fact, I
guess, probably, you can walk
us through the setup steps.
But it really is hey, this is
the code that you should be
using on your own.
WOLFF DOBSON: And because it's
an API, you can expand it
anyway you want.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
Well, let's take a look at how
we're going to set this up.
For you to use these tools,
you're going to need to host
them someplace.
They're just a couple
of HTML pages and
some JavaScript pages.
You'll need to put
them someplace.
Localhost even works
for testing.
You're going to need
to link a web
application in the console.
And you're going to need to go
into these JavaScript and the
HTML files and replace
couple of constants--
in this case, CLIENT_ID,
APP_ID, and in the
Hide-o-matic, you need
the leaderboard.
So even if you don't have a
web version of your game--
TODD KERPELMAN: --which probably
applies to a lot of
our mobile developers.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly--
a lot of your developers.
You're going to need to link
a web application anyway.
And this web application
is actually your game.
So you should be careful with
those credentials like you
would normally.
TODD KERPELMAN: So sorry, just
to clarify, I'm not going to
create a new application that's
my admin for my Angry
Fruit game.
I'm actually going to go into
my Angry Fruit game and I'm
going to link to
a new web-based
client ID for this game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, it's
a web version of
your Angry Fruit game.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And you're going
to fill out where you want it
to point to, and you're going
to create a client ID.
And when you create the client
ID for the web console, you
need to set your JavaScript
origins to wherever you're
hosting these pages.
In this case, I have it on
localhost, but you could also
host it just on a server inside
your firewall, or even
public, although you'd
have to be pretty
careful with that URL.
It is worth noting that
this is, in fact, a
version of your game.
It's just a version of your game
with your game missing
and just the leaderboards and
the scoreboard stuff in there.
And so if you have a JavaScript
origin set to
localhost, it means
that anybody else
can download this.
And they can go to the web
version of your game and they
can pull out the client ID and
the app ID and paste those in
your things and unlock all
the achievements and give
themselves arbitrary score.
They won't be able to do the
management tasks, because you
have to be an owner or
on the tester list
to use those things.
But they will be able to,
obviously, just set their
scores arbitrarily.
And you want to be careful
with that.
So I would advise, if your game
is launched, you probably
want to set your JavaScript
origin to something besides
localhost--
probably an internal server
that's inside your firewall.
OK.
Let's go onto the Q&A.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, all right.
Oh.
You got something changing
your JavaScript origins.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Why would
you want to do this?
WOLFF DOBSON: Again, after
you've launched your game, you
might still want to do
management tasks.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
WOLFF DOBSON: So you
can change that
from inside the API.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we'd go to
the API's console, or I guess,
coming soon, the
cloud console.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: And this is
basically where we could
change our settings, to be like,
I don't want to be on
localhost anymore.
I want to be on
internalserver.google.com or whatever.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, probably
not google.com,
unless you're us.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
probably not you.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
Here we go.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So first question,
it looks like--
very clearly, I would want to
use this hide mechanism if it
looks like somebody is doing
something kind of nefarious or
they're being a jerk, and
they're like, hey, I'm going
to get a fake score upon there
because I'm a lead hacker.
So why not just ban
these players?
WOLFF DOBSON: You
could ban them.
But then they might notice and
they might get angry and come
after you again.
But also, really, they're still
going to appear in their
social scoreboards.
And so if somebody looks and
says, yeah, he's still got the
highest score, that's great,
but they may be ruining the
experience for the people
in the public boards.
So this allows them just to be
like, well, they're not going
to appear in the
public boards.
And then when they look at the
public board, they'll still
see themselves.
But if anybody else looks at
the public board, they will
not be there.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So that's probably something
to make sure--
hiding means hide from
everybody except
the cheating or the--
WOLFF DOBSON: Adverse--
TODD KERPELMAN: --the
hidden player.
WOLFF DOBSON: The
adverse player.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
So they wouldn't even know
that they've been hidden
unless they were to get another
friend with an account
to look at the leaderboards.
WOLFF DOBSON: Look at
public leaderboards.
TODD KERPELMAN: Public
leaderboards.
WOLFF DOBSON: They will appear
in the social leaderboards.
TODD KERPELMAN: And that looks
like a lot of work.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: I suppose the
other advantage is if you hide
someone that you suspect has
gotten a score through
nefarious purposes and that it
turns out they're just a
really, really good player,
you do have the option to
unhide them.
WOLFF DOBSON: You can put
them right back in.
TODD KERPELMAN: And all
of their old scores
will still be there.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
And another real use is that
you have a bunch of testers
who've been playing
it in beta.
And they all have really
high scores.
And you're like, I don't want to
destroy your guys's score,
but really, we need to get that
off there so people can
have a chance.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
makes sense.
Now, using this tool, could I--
for instance, my customer
service people, someone emails
me and says, hey, I didn't get
this achievement.
Can we grant them that
achievement using this tool?
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
You need a valid access token
for each account to be able to
unlock achievements or lock
achievements for them.
TODD KERPELMAN: So the idea is
this is really used for--
WOLFF DOBSON: For unrevealed--
set back to revealed.
TODD KERPELMAN: So this
is really just
used for testing purposes.
My testers have earned
the achievements.
They want to practice earning
the achievements again or they
want to test that
scenario again.
So we can get them all back
to the original state.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, the player
hiding is the only thing you
can do to somebody else, and
again, only if you're an owner
of the application.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I guess that links into our
third question-- sort of what
you mentioned.
How do I know who has access
to these tools?
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
So for the testing tools, you
just need to be on the tester
list in the Play Games
developer console.
TODD KERPELMAN: And chances
are-- that's the one you've
got to add so that people can
try your game before any game
services has been published,
basically.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
And the owner of the application
is the person who
can do the hiding
and unhiding.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And you have to
sign in as that person when
you're using this application.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
All right.
So even if somehow I were to get
your client ID and you're
on localhost.
I'm still using that, and I
do all that stuff you said
before, I'm still limited
in what I do.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
It makes you log in as that
person that you can't make
change anything, or as an owner,
and hopefully, you're
not leaking your owner
credentials.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: That
would be bad.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
Well, all right.
Great.
I think that's everything we
have on management tools.
So Wolff, we've got to get you
out of here so we have time
for our graph.
So you're on.
JAVIER SNIDER: Hello.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh,
hey, it's Javier.
Javier, welcome.
Why don't you introduce
yourself?
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
Well, I'm Javier Snider from
the Google Play Games team.
Well, here I am.
TODD KERPELMAN: And you're here
to talk about a graph
that we're about to see.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: I've got
this whole seat here.
I think I really only need the
edge, because we're about to
reveal it right now.
JAVIER SNIDER: OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey,
check that out.
JAVIER SNIDER: OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what
are we looking at?
JAVIER SNIDER: What is this?
TODD KERPELMAN: What is it?
JAVIER SNIDER: OK.
Well, this is an improvement
in the unreliable latency
between peers and real-time
multiplayer games.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So I know we launched
multiplayer matchmaking at
Google I/O a few months ago.
Since then, we've been
integrating and improving.
One of those areas has
been match quality.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah,
match quality.
So what is this?
This is a factor that we are
always trying to improve in
our matchmaking system so the
players can have a better
experience in the matches
that we create.
TODD KERPELMAN: It looks like a
couple weeks ago, this graph
took a nice little dip.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: What
happened here?
JAVIER SNIDER: So
what is this?
We started considering the broad
geographic place of our
players to estimate the latency
that they are going to
have when we form the match.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So you basically now prefer--
if I'm somewhere in, say,
Seattle, you're saying, hey,
we're going to try and match you
with other people in the
Pacific Northwest area, because
chances are you'll
have better latency than if we
match you with somebody in--
JAVIER SNIDER: Exactly.
So this is something tricky,
because we don't know the
right latency after the match is
formed, and at that point,
it's too late to choose
a different player.
TODD KERPELMAN: You can't
kick someone out
for having low latency.
JAVIER SNIDER: No,
of course not.
So what we have to do is to
collect data for all the
matches between all the regions
around the world.
And that data, we estimate
what is likely to be the
latency between two players
in different regions.
TODD KERPELMAN: Ah.
So it doesn't necessarily have
to be in the same region.
If we know that, for some
reason, City A and City B have
a really good internet
connection between them--
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: --your system
would say, oh, it's OK to
match up these two.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes, exactly.
So essentially, we do that.
And with this feature, we get
better quality in the matches.
As you can see the graph, we've
had almost 15% or 20%
improvement.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
looks nice.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: So were there
any trade offs involved in
having to do this?
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
You always have those.
So if we have a match or if when
we are forming a match we
seen that this match is not
really a good quality or the
latency is likely to be not so
good, but we don't have other
players, probably we have to
wait a little longer to
combine the matches in order
to wait for new players to
arrive and see if they have
better quality or better
expected latency between them.
So this is the trade off, so
maybe we need the players to
wait a little longer before
we find the matches.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So what you're saying is for
instance, I might be ready to
play and the only other player
available right now is in
Australia or somewhere
where it's far away,
probably longer latency.
The system's going to say, we're
not going to match you
up with that guy.
We're going to look for somebody
else with a better
connection.
And so it might take me longer
to get into a match because
I'm not going to play this
guy in Australia.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
But of course, we don't want our
players to wait too much.
So what we also estimate is the
waiting time to another
player to appear for this
particular game.
And if we think that it's going
to be too long, we don't
wait, and combine the
players right away.
TODD KERPELMAN: So you change
the criteria a little bit
based on how popular the game
is, how many players are
playing multiplayer
at that time?
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah, exactly.
And this is something that
is dynamically adjusted.
So for each application, each
variant, and each moment, we
calculate all these variables
and decide if wait is a good
idea or not.
So we prioritize these two
things to have a good quality,
but also not to wait too much
that the player drops the
match or whatever.
TODD KERPELMAN: So for instance,
in a very popular
game, you could afford to reject
players that are too
far away, might not have a good
connection, because we
know that there's constantly new
people coming in and that
I won't have to wait
too much longer to
find a matching player.
Whereas a game where it's just
been released or it's not very
popular, no one's playing
multiplayer, even if some
connection isn't optimal, the
system will say, we're going
to try and match you with them
anyway, because at least it's
better to have some game
than no game at all.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah, exactly.
That's the idea.
And by the way, we don't
reject players.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sorry.
JAVIER SNIDER: We just
choose to combine
them with other players.
TODD KERPELMAN: You're right.
I should pick better language.
We love all of our players.
We just--
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
JAVIER SNIDER: OK.
So this is it.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
very cool.
So basically, our players should
be noticing a better
multiplayer experience.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah,
that's the idea.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
And over time, as you adjust
these matching systems, and I
guess as more people start
playing multiplayer, they'll
start to see improvements,
as well.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
So another thing that maybe in
the future happens is if a
player or developers want to
improve based on the skills of
the players, we can do
some similar stuff.
TODD KERPELMAN: I've seen
requests for that in the
public database--
hey, I want to match advanced
players with advanced players
or people of the same
difficulty level.
But I guess you do have a good
point where there's a trade
off there, where if we start
not matching people with
potential opponents just because
maybe they're not the
same skill level, the wait
time is going to go up.
And depending on how picky we
get, the more factors we have
to wait until we get a perfect
match, the longer the wait
time could be.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yes.
But of course, we have to
consider all these features or
these parameters when we try to
combine matches of players.
And of course, always,
the wait time is a
very important factor.
And we don't want our players
to wait too much.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So yeah, it sounds like
a tricky problem.
JAVIER SNIDER: Yeah, it's
not a simple one.
And again, the major problem is
that you don't know all the
information until
it's too late to
take the optimal decision.
So you have to estimate a lot of
details to do this process.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, I'm
glad you're working
on it and not me.
All right.
Well, I think that wraps up
this episode of Game On!
I'd like to thank Wolff and
Javier for joining us.
And we will see you
in two weeks.
Thank you very much,
internet audience.